So if it goes inside of a cell, then it's already into a chronic disease.
Then that can be, it's not going to, normally, if you take a chronic disease, I mean,
they've had it in a little time.
A person can have a Borrelia bacteria, a Lyman infection that have it go into a spirochet
inside the cell phase, actually, within a matter of hours.
Northerly, the window is about, you say, about two weeks to 60 days on most people.
That means, if I got bit by a tick, and I got this rash, and I found the tick on me,
and I have a fever, and I go into the doctor, I typically have about two weeks to 60 days,
pushing it at the far end.
That taking it at antibiotic is actually going to kill this thing, and it will never become chronic blood.
That would be twice in my life.
So the first time was back 20 years ago, oh gosh, longer than I probably, I don't remember.
That I got bit by a tick, I had a bull's eye reaction.
It was, if I would have had a digital camera at that time, you would have had a textbook.
Floating it early enough right now, because it literally took, looked like it took red lipstick
and drew a bull's eye on my stomach right there.
Went to the doctor to get an antibiotic immediately, and he said no.
So I had a friend that was an MD that wrote a prescription that understood chronic liability,
gave me a prescription.
Not to not again, never take antibiotics, never take any drugs, so it just worked for me,
just like that, not to not be in about literally within two hours, all their symptoms went away.
So I was very fortunate to catch it and to know what I know.
But what I knew then was nothing compared to what I don't know about Lyme disease.
Second time was just two years ago, I wasn't even outside, actually went outside,
walked around the person's house to do some grounding of their house.
I actually was dressed like something like this and didn't have any tick bite,
didn't have any noticeable idea that I had any sort of infection whatsoever.
But I went in and talked to the people of their patients of mine, he was a cancer patient of mine,
talked to them for about 15 minutes in the house, they had this cute little puppy that would not leave me alone,
but had this puppy, it took me about a week to figure out that what I had was Lyme.
I thought I had food poisoning because I get violent reaction with Lyme.
I get super sick.
I missed, I think, two days of work, I never missed work.
So it was, I was definitely sick, didn't even daughter of me that I had Lyme disease.
I wasn't even, it was in March, I think, I had been outside at all, I thought, okay, what's that?
Dog.
Sure enough, that's what I had.
Took some antibiotics, knocked it right out of me, but I haven't had an issue.
So I have not been in this chronic infection stage.
My daughter on the other hand is 31 years old, my oldest daughter.
We used to live up in the woods and she ended up with Lyme disease.
Never had the acute infection, never had that bull's eye rash.
Never was sick with the flu, I don't know if I can remember.
Starting to get a joint swelling all over, we were doing a lot of work out of the woods.
Of course, I thought she was just being a baby, get to work, I'm going to love your dad.
No, she had Lyme disease, her other client told me, I was not like a horrible parent, now we figured it out.
I'm actually not work with her and we came up with an herbal remedy for her, and she's in the chronic Lyme phase
that we're going to talk about at depth here, that burbles work for her.
So somebody like my daughter, Jessie, who was in the chronic Lyme phase, she has very little symptoms.
Maybe once a year she'll call me and say, dad, my life's cleared up by these, I'll swollen up or something like that.
And she travels for a living, teaches seminars around the country, a real estate,
and she will call me in from Pittsburgh or something, and I'll say, go find them.
This is what you need to get, blah, blah, blah, blah, because she's in the chronic stage.
She's not in the third phase.
Now, most people that are very debilitated from Lyme disease are not in what I term the chronic stage.
They are actually in an automobile stage that we're going to talk about in just a couple of minutes.
So you know with me?
So you have the acute infection that's curable by antibiotics.
And I think it's truly curable on many people, if you catch it,
at a time when the bacteria is circulating in the bloodstream, it has not yet gone intracellular.
And antibiotics will kill it.
Rely is a gram-negative bacterium, similar to some other gram-negative bacterias.
Then, unfortunately, have the ability to go inside of a cell and hide inside the cell,
and disable that barker.
Remember I said what a cell is infiltrated by a pathogen?
It gives off this little barker, this little protein barker.
On the outside of the cell membrane, telling the immune system that it's been infiltrated
and it insists it destroys the cell.
There's several bacteria, live, burrelia, be one of them, H. Pymor, I mean another one.
It has the ability to go intracellular and disable that barker.
So the immune system doesn't know that the bacteria is hiding inside the cell,
and can reproduce inside the cell and disrupt cellular function.
Thereby may be you ill.
It's an opportunistic organism.
So the opportunity arises, that there is less macrophages,
and white blood cells, the pH-1 cytokine circulating in the spaces between the cells
that goes outside of the cell, and it starts reproducing.
Outside of the cell, it hides in other cells and it just takes you sick.
And your immune system is unable to kill it.
Now, you can stay in that phase.
And if you have a healthy enough immune system, you can stay in this phase
and you can have just little line outbreaks, you know, every period of time
or whatever, like my daughter about once a year, maybe sometimes twice a year,
sometimes she'll go more than once, more than a year,
before she has some little thing that she recognizes as an outbreak.
Now, she may have other symptoms that she doesn't necessarily recognize as a line outbreak,
but she recognizes joint issues with her symptoms.
And that is a person that's in a chronic, live state,
but it's very manageable, typically with things that will help stimulate
the immune system function, a healthy, aerobium system.